I can't go with you here just take a
walk around the block or something I
can't keep going for walk every time you
have to poo just work with me you closer
today that's so tired no he's not gay I
don't have to date him just because he's
not gay is attractive and lives with me
am I on speakerphone mom
you gotta stop doing the hello Graham
hey what's up dad ask you something
really quick you're like don't you have
to be completely honest Tori okay why do
women go to the bathroom in pairs here
it's street cleaning in five minutes we
have to move our cars what all right
cool are you coming yeah just shut the
door Vincent okay
you probably want to tell anyone it's to
change each other's tampons makes sense
is it because you have a Borneo Oh
oh my god Krum hold on this happens
every morning yes
gross hey guys hey what's up
no no hey do you know why girls go to
the bathroom and everyone thinks that
we're just going to talk about stuff
literally we hardly talk it's a lot of
it's a lot so how do I fully visible ah
sweet relief
hey hey hey okay
raise it hey give me yeah you can get it
yeah get Zoo
oh no it's not like that we're just
roommates nothing sexual at all
gross you should see meat spaghetti
it'll show how long is that string for
real it's standard two and a half inches
what yeah we have to tuck it up pull
give tuck it up lap it over between the
lips good night
yeah yeah oh yeah we did up until 3:00
a.m. watching Harry Potter so how does a
lot of commitment I know I feel like you
might be emotionally unavailable though
I have it like a track record of dating
emotionally unavailable guys and I want
to do that again both you see how it
goes
PETA later yeah it's my middle name
Elizabeth baby
yeah it's Elizabeth Han what's yours uh
we're not there yet
why why not
Garak white you fix the wall
why would I fix it I don't know use your
Harry Potter magic I only use my Harry
Potter magic for good and there's no
reason you can't fix it magic isn't real
cake how dare you